the Joe Rogan experience you brought
Brett you know I'm on this all meat diet
I know ring bread [ __ ] but it you have a
family oh oh I'll deviate a little bit
I'll deviate you might want to take a
look at it later i DV ate it over this
weekend and yeah I went to Disneyland
and I had ice cream and then Friday
night or Saturday night Saturday night I
had pasta I had all kinds I had Girl
Scout cookies ate a bunch of Girl Scout
cookies and dude I'm telling you Sunday
my back was hurting
really one day my back was hurting
everything was like my knee was hurting
all this like inflammation it's crazy
puffy yeah one day back two days because
today's Tuesday so I ate corner warm
Monday and Tuesday everything's normal
yet no really no more aches and pains so
you were full on meat for a whole month
a whole month but 120 meals a day -
usually - yeah maybe a small meal around
noon and their workout and then dinner
alright and that no eggs no yeah I would
eat eggs eggs and fish eggs fish meat me
just nobody bows at all no that's roots
no no right of course no I had an olive
no two olives and two pieces of chili
mango the entire month - glorious a host
but the pieces of chili mango I
legitimately felt guilty I love chili
mango I just never had chili oh my god
really now is one of the greatest
creations what is it it's chili pepper
mango dried mangoes
but with chili powder it's uh it's a
Mexican big big hit and Mexican
community right yeah yeah it's so good
because it's got the sweetness from the
dried mangoes yeah but then it's got the
spiciness from the chili powder oh
that's right up my alley ah so good a
two pieces I was only going to eat one I
was like [ __ ] then we have another
one that second one I'm like oh no what
have I done
why'd you decide to do it in the first
place the diet yeah well because
January's world carnivore month and I
know quite a few people that have done
it and that have had some serious
results and serious results with
autoimmune issues too
I have vitiligo which is an autoimmune
disease it causes you to have these
patches where you don't have pigment oh
really and this month I have the best
results sort of ever had with vitiligo
we bought really ends it's it comes and
goes it comes and goes
depending upon how well I'm taking care
of myself
treatments and stuff like that but this
this month it's got all these spots fill
in like a pretty rapid rate really
people with eczema I've had spectacular
results with it now what if you were to
suggest to someone who's wouldn't eat
just meat what percentage meet the after
going through this do you think you
would I think the problem is not plants
as much as the problem really is refined
sugar carbohydrates and [ __ ] that's
what I think I think that's the problem
just cheese counting that you can eat
cheese you can eat cheese you can eat
cheese really animal product yeah
I think for most people the real problem
is junk you know candy sugar yeah pasta
various glorious bread
[Applause]